ん
ameba
anh 糸
パダです
ッピー to do
うっま
paddy 付
ううっうぅうう do
voodoo
ん
うん
pa
はじめましてバケツドラなうの正と申します
今パフォーマンスを見てもらって
皆さんの頭に一つの疑問が重い感じると思います
それは
こんなことじゃないでしょうか
チゲ長すぎじゃねぇ
いや
単純に見ても日芸めっちゃ長いですよねこれマーナーセンチって書いてあるんですけど
20センチあります
2年近く沿ってません
でよく
仙人みたいだねって言われます
まぁこんなことじゃないですよね多分こっちにも後ろにあるバケツとかこういうものが
気になってるんだと思います
今僕の目の前に並んでいるこの理由子達は
ガソリンスタンドでもらったごみのバケツです
一個一個音が違うんですっていうのもそこが凹んでいたりとか膨らんでいたいとかそう
いう事で音が違います
あとはこうやっていっ
そこを角度をつけてあげたりとか
中に物を入れることによって音を変える工夫をしています
これは
皆さんねーにはある普通のボールです
叩くとか
新原みたいな音がします
でもシンバルじゃないです
でこのパイプこれはホームセンターで買ったものです
オーストラリアのディジュリドゥー民族楽器を模して作ったものです
唇を振動させることによって音を鳴らします
こんな感じです
さっきの演奏では循環呼吸というテクニックを使って
を通すと止めずに呼吸だけはずっとしてました
循環呼吸っていうのは
口に溜まっている空気を押し出している時に鼻から息をはいに入れることです
気になる方はインターネットで調べてみてください
ていました
では今日の話に移りたいと思います僕のメインはまあパフォーマンスなんでまぁ余談
程度に聞いてください
これは楽しく生きるためのアイディアです
ハードルを下げるということ
今日はこのテーマについて話を進めたいと思います
ではハードルを下げるとはいったいなんだと
それは
今まで意識を向けてなかったことに目を向けたり気がついたりすることだと僕は考えて
います
それはすなわち
当たり前だと思っていることをそれを当たり前と思わなくなることです
改めて何かに目を向けることによって今まで気がつかなかった楽しさを発見するという
ことです
ではそのハードルが下がることがどう
楽しさにつながっていくのか
まず何かに目を向けることそして気がつくことです
それがハードルを下げることです
そしてそのことについて考えてみることです
そしてそれを行動に移すこと
その結果楽しさだったり喜びそういうものを発見できると僕は考えています
これが楽しさを発見する流れです
この話を踏まえて僕の話を進めていきたいとおもいます
では
なぜ僕がこのバケツを
叩き始めたのかその話をしたいと思います
理由は2つです
ドラムを持ち運ぶのが単純に重かったということ
そしてもう一つはインターネットで見たバケツドラマーの動画がめちゃくちゃ格好だっ
たということです
僕には
路上パフォーマンスをする友達がいます
彼は僕に路上パフォーマンスの価値とか魅力ってものをたくさん教えてくれました
例えば路上で演奏することによって
誰かが喜んでくれたり見ず知らずの人が笑顔になってくれることそしてその対価として
チップが入るということ
そんな話聞いたら自分も何か老将パフォーマンスやりたいなあと思ったんです
そして
路上パフォーマンスをするためにオーストラリアのネイル5連という町に行きました
メルボルンは路上パフォーマンスがすごく盛んなところで
まあメッカみたいなところです
僕はもともとドラムをやっていたので単純に路上でドラムをたたこうって思ってました
でも
ドラムを運ぶのがめっちゃ重くてそれができなかったんです
結局そのドラムっていうことに執着してしまって路上パフォーマンスできなかったん
です
だからせっかくカッタードラムセットもすぐに手放してしまいました
でもそんなときにインターネットで見たバケツドラマーの動画思い出したんです
ドラムがダメだったら
まあバケツ叩いてみようかなバケツだったら軽いしすべてに入るそうだし
なんかできそうだなそんな軽い気持ちで僕バケツドラマーになりました
ではそのバケツドラムっていうものがどうハードルが下がるのか
それを説明した図がこちらです
バケツドラムに出会うまでの僕は路上パフォーマンスをすること=
ドラムを叩くことになったんです
でものはドラムは運ぶのが重い大変だってそんなことが僕の中で路上パフォーマンスを
するハードルを高くしてしまったんです
でも
籠城パフォーマンスてドラムを叩くことだけじゃないですよね
バケツをたいだって路上パフォーマンスになる
そう自分の中で気付いた瞬間に
僕の中の路上パフォーマンスに対するハードルは一気に下がりました
その結果路上パフォーマンスをすることの価値だったり楽しさを自分で発見することが
できたんです
そうやって路上パフォーマーとしてバケツドラマーとして活動していく中である考えが
自分の中にできました
それは
お金をかけなくても音楽を楽しむことができる
これは僕が活動していく中で大切にしている
一つの価値観です
僕は
路上パフォーマンスをしながら日本全国ヒッチャーいるで旅をしてました
ん
そんな時にこんなことがあったんです
三重県の四日市という場所です
そこで路上パフォーマンスしていると
ある外国人の親子がパフォーマンスを見てくれたんです
小学校1年生くらいのこんな小さな男の子とそのお父さんでした
パフォーマンスが終わったあとには自分の元へ駆けつけてくれて話しかけてくれたん
です
でもその男の子歳だったのか
お父さんから離れないで僕の顔も一切見てくれなかったんです
でまぁこんな髭面してたらまあそれもしょうがないってその時は思ったんですけど
でも
次の日の朝にその子の母親からメールが届きました
息子が家に帰ってきて
麺を輝かせながらバケツを叩き始めました
そんなの兵法のメールでした
でそのメールには写真が1枚添付されていて
その男の子がバケツとかフライパンとかボールをもうひっくり返してもう一生懸命たの
ソイ叩いている写真だったんですね
僕の
パフォーマンスを見ることによって
その男の子は
新しい楽しさに気付いてくれたんです
そしてそのことが僕はすごく嬉しかったんです
その親子が僕に改めて自分のパフォーマンス
バケツドラムというパフォーマンスの価値を教えてくれました
僕たち日本人
お金をかけて音楽を楽しむことが当たり前になっていると僕は思ってます
お金をかけて音楽を楽しむことは決して
悪いことではありません
でもそのことが僕たちの音楽を楽しむハードルを少し開けちゃってるんじゃないかなっ
て僕は思ってます
だから
お金をかけなくてもお金なんてなくても音楽って楽しめるぞってああ
僕はこのパフォーマンスを通じて表現していきたいし伝えたいと思ってます
ハードルを下げたいて思ってます
そしてそれは音楽だけにとどまるものじゃなくてなんかいろんなことに通じてるって
思っているんです
好きなことだけに目を向けるんじゃなくて
今まで気にも留めなかったことに目を向けることによって
今まで気づかなかった楽しさ新しい楽しさが発見できると僕は思ってます
例えば
友達とスポーツをして遊んでいる時
自分たちで考えた独自のルールを追加してみるとか
あとはー
今まで使ったことがない食材とか馴染みのない食材を使って料理に挑戦してみるとか
たぶん何でもいいんだと思います
でもそういうことの先に何かで会ったことない楽しさとか新しい発見
僕が待っていると思うんです
今まで気にも留めなかったことに目を向けることによって
新しい楽しさを発見できると思います
そして
今まで感じていた楽しさってものがまた違った角度から楽しく感じることができると僕
は考えています
ハードルを下げるということ
それは目を向けることをそして気がつくことです
当たり前と思っていることを
当たり前と思わなくなることです
僕は普通のドラムというものからこのバケツとかパイプとかこういうものに目を向ける
ことによって
自分の人生が大きく変わりました
収納ドラムを叩いていたら気がつかなかった楽しさとか
価値観がたくさんあったし
バケツドラムに目を向けたからこそ出会うことができた
素晴らしい人たちがたくさんいます
いろんなことに
興味を持ってほしいですそしてそのことについて考えてみてほしいです
そうすれば今まで気がつかなかったたましたとか
今まで見落としていた楽しさをまた発見するチャンスが来ると思うんです
アンテナを張り巡らしてください
そして考えることを止めないでください
そうすれば日々の生活に
楽しさを発見できるだけじゃなくて幸せとか感動とか喜びとかなんかいろんなものを
見えてくると思うんです
今まで見えなかったものが
あなたにへ
どんどん見えるようになりますように
ハードルを下げるということ
楽しく生きるためのアイディアの話でした
ありがとうございました